L
A
BRTOR O
D.
ULU YOCO IMAD KEAT ME CRI
IF
RECONGSE PSSASAD TETA STUO T ASK
REA FOVEN IGGOMERNNTO T
IGVEINSTE A LITILCA
NTPOOPNE
NO IITS AT  CMERI AT  TNDHA
YATOUTOAV HE  V USEUEAGMS TERSH
BUKELI APO OSEF R.
:HOST M NEWICEXO,RAEMOCCTI
ERCALL.
CALLER:OOD RNG.IN
IITOUOBS VITOS U E  MYOEE ARTH
VIE. HIMER
T:GUES '' SFET ELORRYOR FE. M
ERCALLINPS ETESE UD Y.OU
THINYOU INE ARBEUSG ED
AG
YOARU EBV OLYUS NE  AOTBL
E
A OFDGJUE CTHA CRA.ER
UEMY QIOSTN ISTRHE WN
P US
ENPROV AO  TBES BADHIOR F T
Y UNCOTRTE EASPSIN W
FASOR
LELITTIR GLL, LSWIDMOU Y AOUIT Y
WERO WNGADND A FEORWA AY IL W
O
ECBEU  DAGVEEID N?AI
GUT:ES I D'O'K THT IN
WAI S
IVDECE.ED
REI TEESPRENDPL PEOSEACE CUOFD
S RISEOU.IMCRES
ESREI PRO.TEEND PS SJ.IM.ON
PRI RED ENESTEEONYMA PUE PLYO
D'T LDE IKANWHOM SE N'I O DO
'T
.LIKE
S ATTH I. JMYOB
REI TEESPRENEIEPD ST
N.
S I WAWYS HILA.ER
AIHE PDE  MERR FOEVTEMIY NU
IP
THT ENWI
IM H.
WEKE WOROUD T AL  DEAHETHWI T
GORNHANTME TESRET PRTHTEEND
O
IVARMPATETR SOFGTENH ITUR O S
N
DIR THE
ID SE.
I ONLLWI CTONUTIE D EF DENETH
OPPE T ALENDST CHEONN.UTITIO
EPDIEISTN USNOD T ME.
I MEVENER OFANT Y OUHE T Y
NG
N,WOME N D IIDOTNO KWNG YOU
WON WEREVENV IOL
SI WADUNT IROD CETO HIM BY A
WI.
TOWAI S  HLDE WLO AAS C
ESPRENTO  TESE THPROFENIDT
HAD.AR
MYIASS AOCONTIIT W WTHH EM
ASLA
ELRGY ACDECAMIND AITHA TT
BESI PMERELNTDEIA --
SIOFPRESALON WNHE S IEDPOUPRT
HI
N  W--HEESREI PRHITEEND
CWII LLETIONNU TNDDEO FEHE T
COTITINSTU,ONIL I WINCOL NT
O
DENDFE THETH SIXMEME AND I ANTND
WIITO RO PLYUDSEEC BAU
M
INSERVTHG EER INTF TSES OETH
FLERU O L T AAWND
HECO
TITINSTU.ON
STHO:LA DALS,EX TASBLRE, PU
.
CALL: TOUNKHA YAKOR F T
Y
CA.LL
WOI UL TLID KEKNO OW IFLA AN
D COULT FLREEC
TONHE
LAREIPONTISHET BHEENWE TSOW PER
OFER GOVENNMT, E UTECIVDAN
RECONGL,IOSSNAOW IS  FITTHWI
ATA S IMETENT HRDEAARO FM
ITCOMMMBE TEMEAT, ERSTGIN
RECONGSS H S TADHEE POR TO
IMT.HMACEN
I DERSODTOHA TT  MNEA
Y THE
E D HATHOWLESO PBR TERO GIN
S ARCHGEEA IOFMP.MECHNT
WWHATLD BTHREI NEPT EXST
?
I OLOGE  IR FOMYCEORGNAN
.GU
T:ES AT  IISNXC EELNTLE
ONESQUTI
AT DSOE NN  MOTEANO IITS
BJSUECUDTOT  JREIAICL
EWVI.
EVT Y ERACOFONGRS ESINCOACRD
G
EDTO FTALERIS PAP 78ENRI WTT
BYN ILAMTOISUBJEOCT T
JUEVALCI RW.IE
ITMP IEDMELENTISEREDALT PERAP
.78
Y EVERTACCO OF , RENGSSONMIHALT
THIDSA, LA VATIOES TETH
NSCOONTUTITIS IOI V
THWEER CS GRONESHAULWOD VE
E
R POWEEA ITOMP ACHDERE PSINT
D BASECO NONONTITINSTUALON
IAITCRERETND A WER HETHOU CSRT
ULCODER INTS NEVE IAST QUE
E
'DON'OWT KNNSHE T A.R WETO
N HITASEEEREV BND ES TTEDAN
NEGHMIT  TR VEBE
TEESD.
R OUTUNSCOTIS ONTI IRFT NOPET.EC
IMTHE ENACPEHMT PIDEROW DOT N
RCOVEACNC IAPY.IT
A ENESPRIDDIWHT O DONOD T
ANNGHI B BADJU HUTE  A HSTAD
AROSTKE WNDAS C NOTLEAPABF O
RNVEIN
WETOAV HE MENDHE
TICONS.TITUON
E IF WABINTHK E USOFER POW
BOUSHLDCRE A  FERITIA
OR
HMPEIMACE T,EN WVEHA A
ONGALITIENO  TAM
THD E
TITINSTU.
I YOUBDOT ULD WOU LET G A
F
S VOTEATR FOTH
ERMEMBOTOFS  BIEPAH RTSOULD
SAIVATTH GESOOAR F T
UC MH
R POWEGR CTOONS.ES
ABUSOWOFE  P?ER
REWE AOIOT N GVO TNGO
FTR
.THAT
JUTH ASTS ERA FRSMEOTID D N
E
FODMMAR LAATISINTRN.IO
NGCOANSSRE CTNOT  JUSATD ADTHO T
ETHITON CSTWIIOUTN OUTHT
DIAMEN TNGHEITON CST
IOUTN,
THSOMEDOG INI T TH WOULD
O
HEIF T AWEY REO EDSK TECLINUD
ABE ER POFOW
.
:HOST ANLAOWER DSHHAZ,IT T
U
THFOR ERCOE NV TTISAONSHI
G.RNMOIN
GUT: YHA TNK.OU
STHO:T THAOE DORITS  F'OD TAY'S
INWASHOUONGT J
ALRN.
JOENRETHY E YO OSTF . DURAY
ONAP[CTIRICOS PYTIT GHNAALON
SABLCAE E LLTEIT20RPCO. ]19
AP[CG ONTIINMERFPEORHEBYD  T
NAAPALON CG ONTIINUTSTINIT
RH ICISIBPOESNS I FLEOR
TSCA
COIOPTN ANENNTT RAACD CU.CY
NCSIVIT .OICAP]RG
♪